E-Modes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on.
But I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch E-Modes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap a Fog Champ, keep a Forehead, Bible Thumb, Twitch E-Modes.
I remember typing Dan's game, Forehead Swift Rage, PJ Salt and Fail Fish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch E-Modes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap a Fog Champ, keep a Forehead, Bible Thumb, Twitch E-Modes.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me, his doggy E-Mode reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I missed E-Modes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch E-Modes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap a Fog Champ, keep a Forehead, Bible Thumb, Twitch E-Modes.
Twitch E-Modes from long ago made you feel...
Twitch E-Modes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Twitch E-Modes from long ago...
Twitch E-Modes from long ago made you feel...
Twitch E-Modes...